PROFESSOR 1: I have
the distinct pleasure
of having a Professor Raffaella Sadun
from the Business School of Harvard
talking to us about
leadership and management.
RAFFAELLA SADUN: My dad is a surgeon.
My brother is a hospital manager.
Every night at home growing
up, I would essentially
be in the middle of this conversation
between a surgeon resisting
the managers and the hospital
manager trying to convince
the surgeon, look, this matters.
And I'll tell you why.
So it's a question that
has always fascinated me.
That said, at a personal
level, the reason
why I'm so intrigued by trying to find
a way for surgeons and hospital managers
to communicate and work together
in the interest of the patients
and the whole organization.
At a higher level, I
really think that it's
important to understand ways
in which managers can really
improve firm performance and
through improving firm performance,
have any impact on the
growth of the economy.
So I really think that now we
have all the tools established--
this link between the micro level--
what happens in the context of a firm
and what happens in the
context of a country.
It's very important to understand
the internal communication
within these organizations
and really understanding
what is the common objective.
This is going to be the
key to prove performance
for each individual hospital.
But I feel like this is really the step.